now tomorrow marks international women's
day coronavirus have
of course affected everyone in so many
ways but there have been some issues
that have hit women particularly hard
whether it's on child care job prospects
or domestic abuse
yesterday i spoke to the executive
director of un women fumes
and i asked her whether things have
improved or got worse for women around
the world in the last year
well we unfortunately have been
hard hit by the pandemic and some of the
gains that we made
in the last two decades especially
are under significant threats
during the pandemic women have lost most
of the jobs about two-thirds of the jobs
that were lost
airway jobs that belongs to women and
this is because women tend to be at the
lower end
with jobs that are not protected with
jobs that have
do not have enforceable contracts and in
some countries are not even covered by
the labor laws
so it's very easy to get rid of women in
times of crisis
we've seen girls dropping out of school
in larger numbers
again this is one area where we've been
making progress
in the last two decades but also women's
leadership
is not being taken as seriously as we
need
to be taking it serious and we've seen
now
even during this crisis that in the task
teams and committees
that are dealing with covet women are
underrepresented
in 87 countries that we surveys only
about 3.6
have gender equal a
you know a representation of men and
women and you can't have men
fixing the issues that affect women most
it's interesting you're talking
about women in leadership throughout the
pandemic because in
countries where we've had women leaders
there's actually been quite a lot of
praise for how they've dealt with it in
places like new zealand and germany for
instance
absolutely and this year's theme for
international women's day
is on island women's leadership there is
an opportunity here
at the back of this pandemic to actually
promote women's leadership
and we have this evidence of women who
have performed
very well and have managed
the pandemic in in an impressive way
you talked about women in the workplace
and the impact it's had and
of course in the uk it's also had you
know a big
big impact on how women are doing in the
workplace the pandemic so for example
you know 17 mothers in the uk so they've
had to
give up on work during the pandemic uh
mothers on the lowest incomes nine times
more likely
to have lost their jobs and do you worry
that
even in places like the uk and wealthy
nations that the pandemic could
set back women's progress potentially
decades
oh absolutely i mean just for women
sleeping
out of the labor market is
is a big issue and in countries like the
uk where women
did achieve much better representation
in the labor
market it is going to cost us
a a lot to have those
those women now not spending and not
being able to be as independent as they
were
as a as working mothers working women
another aspect that we've seen in the uk
is in domestic violence
the number of people reporting uh
domestic violence the un's described it
as a shadow pandemic how concerned are
you that as we're told to stay at home
it's actually not a safe place for so
many women we have
called this interest
of gender-based violence a pandemic
of its own a shadow pandemic that has
existed
before there was a covert 19
and will continue to exist after private
19 so we need to fight it not just for
what is happening now during the pending
but fight it
for the future as well and deal with it
as a pandemic with all hands on deck in
the context of gender-based violence
our frontline workers are social workers
the police
civil society the judiciary
all of those we need to make decisions
that will prevent
the violence from happening as well as
prosecute
in some countries the increase has been
as high
as 40 percent i'm also interested as
well if you're worried about
uh increased nationalism the country is
effectively looking to
protect themselves because they're
dealing with the crisis
of covid rather than reaching out and
trying to help uh people
in other countries so in the uk for
example you know we've reduced the aid
budget from 0.7 to 0.5
of gdp we've cut aid to yemen
how much of a concern is this for the
u.n it really is concerning us and we
are appealing
for countries to be generous at this
time of need
a solidarity in a time like this
is actually important because in in the
fight against the pandemic
a safety in one country
when there is no safety in another
country is not real safety
we need to fight the pandemic all over
the world and to help each other
because we will not be able to be safer
if one part of the world
is not safe the same thing about driving
countries into
extreme poverty we know that when people
are desperate
they will move around the world so the
people that you are
living exposed to extreme poverty will
show up
on your desktop at some point so we have
to be
a in this all together we are also
concerned about women who are refugees
and migrants and in people who are
refugees and migrants
because covert has tended to push people
out of countries that are hosting them
back to their own countries where
sometimes they do not have the
infrastructure
to survive in their own countries
because they already migrated
to a new countries and sometimes they
don't have the papers to be moving
back and forth so migrants are finding
themselves in very difficult situations
we're also concerned about
equitable distribution of vaccine
because there is
a danger also that
women in some situations
will not be given first preference for
accessing the vaccine if we know about
the preference for for boys the
preference
for men men could easily be in front of
of the line claiming that they are the
ones who are
maybe going out to work confining women
in the home space
which comes with its own complications
so we want governments to pay attention
to executable
distribution of the vaccine and make
sure that women
are not discriminated against just
finally
when i was researching you at the
interview i was just very struck by your
own sort of background
um growing up in south africa a teacher
becoming south africa's first female
deputy president at president
also having five children it's a pretty
impressive cv
and what is it about your own experience
uh growing up
and becoming a a woman that really sort
of drove you
and has inspired you you know i grew up
in
in south africa it's a time of
apartheid so you were thrust into
activism
because of the situation of the country
i also had a mother who was an activist
in her own right
so there was a push from the home front
but also
as a student by friends and
fellow students where activists in the
main and in fact
for people of my age group if you are
not
an activist you really
were somehow on the wrong track
because everything pointed you in a
direction
uh that called on you to take action
about what was happening
in the country it was much easier to be
an activist than to fold your heads
that's very interesting and thank you so
much for being on the program today and
talk a bit about international women's
day we appreciate it
thank you